le commandant massoud l'opposant aux
talibans au pouvoir en afghanistan était
à paris aujourd'hui
il a été reçu par le ministre des
affaires étrangères hubert védrine et il
a lancé un appel à l'aide
philip bester pierre dick c'est d'abord
le chef militaire du seul gouvernement
afghan reconnu par la communauté
internationale que rencontré ce matin le
chef de la diplomatie française
mais au delà ahmad shah massoud est un
symbole l'incarnation de la résistance
au régime taliban
mais une résistance en mauvaise posture
aujourd'hui confiné dans son réduit du
nord-est de l'afghanistan moins de 10%
du territoire
mais si l'on en croit massoud l'heure de
la reconquête a sonné margon réaction
pas l'ingérence pakistanaises et aux
comportements chaque jour plus injuste
des talibans
la résistance s'organise de plus en plus
au sein du peuple dans toutes ethnies
confondues tadjik adhara pachtoune
ouzbek et bientôt vous serez témoin un
soulèvement populaire contre les
talibans
au lendemain de la destruction des
bouddhas de bamiyan et de l'émotion
qu'elle a suscitée dans le monde
cette visite la première de la soude en
europe prend bien sûr un relief tout
particulier au président de l'assemblée
nationale comme à chacun de ses
interlocuteurs politiques
il martèle le même message l'europe les
etats-unis doivent faire pression sur le
pakistan principal soutien des talibans
dans le même temps il lance un appel à
l'aide internationale pour les réfugiés
afghans cohue médiatique partout où il
passe
l'homme suscite un véritable engouement
rencontre impromptue avec yvette roudy
beaucoup sur vous pour des colons dans
les femmes c'est le moi il vaut boire à
cela donne un film que j'aime chez moi
d'apparence et se rencontrent à
l'intérieur
demain direction strasbourg le parlement
européen recevra celui que le mythe
surnomme le lion du pont de chine